elizabeth warren has been one of the
most arduous critics of the legacy
financial system and of course as
cryptocurrencies like bitcoin have shown
up i and many others thought that she
would actually embrace this brand new
technology the thought process is this
is a fair transparent immutable ledger
anyone in the world has access to it
there's immense advantages both from a
superiority and technology but also in
terms of the impact it can have on
society compared to the legacy system
but that is not the position that the
politician has taken instead we have a
recent clip where elizabeth warren is
questioning chain analysis co-founder
jonathan levy she's specifically
concerned about the use of bitcoin and
cryptocurrencies to help russians evade
sanctions and as you'll watch this
you'll see the big question is does she
actually want to learn or she's simply
trying to push a narrative here's the
video so you can take a look for
yourself mr levin let's consider one of
putin's cronies who already has a
billion or so in crypto that he wants to
hide from the governments that are
enforcing sanctions on oligarchs
now can this oligarch make it harder to
trace his money
if he hops from one blockchain to
another if he deposits those tokens into
a couple of wallets that don't require
him to provide identifying information
and if he uses a mixing service that
launders his money with other people's
money
thank you senator so the um the scenario
that you you described um where an
oligarch has a billion dollars to be
able to launder requires significant
amounts of liquidity to be able to
obfuscate that amount of money through
the use of cryptocurrency in fact you
know many times we've been able to
identify i'm sorry let me just remind
you what my question was again what i'm
asking is about the tools that are
available now he may have to break it up
into multiple pieces of who knows 100
million dollars at a crack but the
question i'm asking is does hopping from
one blockchain to another does
depositing tokens in a couple of wallets
that don't require them to provide
identifying information and does using a
mixing service all make it easier for
him to hide his money
so senator the answer to that question
is no because the chain hopping that
occurs you need uh to actually provide
the tokens which in a transparent way
that allows you to move across
blockchains we've actually got software
that allows
chain hopping makes it any easier to
hide your money how about depositing
tokens in wallets that don't require
identifying information you can always
split the money up into wallets that
don't require that would help hide the
money and how about using them
that doesn't remove the record of where
the money actually is but the question
i'm asking is does it make it harder to
track the money no so it doesn't make it
hard to spend money using the racing
service you're telling me doesn't make
it harder to launder money the the daily
liquidity value of mixing services
globally is about 30 million dollars
and we have done extensive work in
tracking large sums of money through
mixers that have led to the arrests of
people and the disruption of their
activity you know i'm actually a little
surprised by your answers since you
charged a lot of money to untangle and
track
assets through the system and the system
keeps developing more ways to obscure
that money and that's part of what you
advertise now of course if you actually
are concerned about are russians using
bitcoin cryptocurrencies to evade
sanctions you probably want to
understand how the systems work do we
have the technology to actually make
sure that this isn't happening and that
seems to be exactly what the chain
analysis founder is trying to do here
but elizabeth warren continues to press
and try to say maybe he doesn't
understand how this works she's
surprised by his answers well that's the
beauty of a transparent open immutable
ledger we can see every single
transaction but one of the interesting
aspects is that even though the system
is transparent there's still protection
of financial privacy for those that are
doing nothing wrong that's the aspect of
pseudonymity that is introduced under
the bitcoin blockchain there's going to
be much much more to come for this story
but ultimately i think what we have to
ask ourselves is do we want to actually
put forward legislation that's
thoughtful and has some sort of value to
it or are we simply looking to push
forward a public narrative one that
makes us feel good about ourselves one
that simply helps us to get re-elected
my questions don't necessarily have
answers but my guess is that bitcoin
cryptocurrencies the open transparent
financial system will remain superior to
the legacy system and i think eventually
every politician both sides of the aisle
will recognize bitcoin is good for
business bitcoin is good for the
everyday citizen
bitcoins also good for the nation state
bitcoin's good for the politicians and
we should do everything we can to
embrace this brand new technology hey
you did you like this video great we
make five of them a day and post them
here on this channel make sure you
subscribe like the video and see you
next time